A REMINDER AT THE BREAKING NEWS
NOW FROM INDIA, ALL 41 WORKERS
WHO ARE TRAPPED IN A COLLAPSED
HIMALAYAN TUNNEL HAVE NOW BEEN
RESCUED.
I CAN GIVE YOU A LOOK ONCE
AGAIN AT THE EXTERIOR OF THE
TUNNEL THAT WE'VE BEEN CLOSELY
WATCHING WHERE THOSE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WERE STUCK,
OF COURSE, FOR THE LAST 17
DAYS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A FINAL
AMBULANCE IT SEEMS OUTSIDE OF
THE TUNNEL ENTRANCE.
LET'S GET BACK TO VEDIKA SUD IN
NEW DELHI.
VEDIKA, IT'S TOUGH TO FIND
WORDS TO EMPHASIZE THE RELIEF
OF THE SUCCESS OF THE 17-DAY
MISSION.
IT'S HAD PLENTY OF SETBACKS.
THE RELIEF OF THE OFFICIALS
THERE, THE FAMILIES, AND INDEED
THE WORKERS THEMSELVES, THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 17 DAYS,
BREATHING FRESH AIR.
WE >> ABSOLUTELY, IT IS NOTHING
SHORT OF A MIRACLE.
THAT IS WHAT A LOT OF OFFICIALS
ON THE GROUND WOULD SAY.
BUT YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
THE STATE AS WELL.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE THEY FACE
WAS THE MACHINE, IT WAS A HOW
HEAVY DRILLING MACHINE THAT
BROKE DOWN REPEATEDLY.
THE LAST TWO METERS THAT WE
COVERED TODAY WAS THROUGH
MANUAL DRILLING.
THEY SENT SCORES OF RESCUE
TEAMS INSIDE THAT DRILLED
THROUGH THE DEBRIS, DRILLED
THROUGH THE MIDDLE.
THIS IS AN ECOLOGICALLY FRAGILE
AREA.
THIS TUNNEL COLLAPSED PARTIALLY
BECAUSE OF A LANDSLIDE AND THIS
RUBBLE IN DEBRIS WAS OF COURSE
UNSTABLE AND ON UNSTEADY
GROUND.
IT WAS EQUALLY DANGEROUS
SENDING RESCUE TEAMS INSIDE AS
IT WOULD BE TO RESCUE THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAPPED INSIDE.
THERE WAS SCORES OF AMBULANCES
HOURS.NDBY OVER THE LAST S
WE ANTICIPATE A LOT OF
MOVEMENTS DURING THE DAY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WOULDAPPEN.
THAT IS WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
41 MEN HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
EXTRACTED FROM THE TUNNEL FROM
A 50 METER PIPE WHICH IS ABOUT
FIFTH D METERS WIDE IN
DIAMETER.
THEY WERE PULLED OUT AFTER
BEING MOUNTED ON STRETCHERS.
THEY ILLUMINATED THE ENTIRE
PASSAGEWAY OF THIS PATH TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE MEN, WHO HAVE
FACED SEVERE TRAUMA, ARE PULLED
OUT GENTLY AND REASSURED THAT
THEY ARE ON THEIR WAY OUT AND
ON THEIR WAY TO SAFETY.
SECONDS LATER, AFTER EVERY MAN
WAS PULLED, OUT THEY WERE
WHISKED AWAY IN AN AMBULANCE
AWAY FROM THE REBEL, JULIA,
AWAY FROM THE DEBRIS, AWAY FROM
DANGER.
THEY WERE PULLED AWAY FROM
UNCERTAINTY WHICH THEY HAD
FACED FOR 16 DAYS.
>> A POLICE SYSTEM WAS USED IN
A FAR SMALLER PIPE THAN YOU ARE
SEEING HERE, WHICH IS THIS
TUNNEL ENTRANCE.
JUST GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING, IT SEEMS ON THE
SIDE IT IS CURTAINS.
WE DID NOT REALLY GET TO SEE
THE REMOVAL OF ANY OF THESE
WORKERS, AS WE SAW THIS
OPERATION TAKE PLACE OVER THE
PAST HOUR.
THEY WERE WHISKED INTO
AMBULANCES FOR THE MOST PART
AND TAKEN AWAY, EVEN AS WE SAW
THEIR CELEBRATIONS.
VEDIKA, WE WILL HEAR TALES OF
HEROISM THAT TOOK PLACE
THE PAST 17 DAYS.
IN PARTICULAR, AS YOU SAID,
WHEN THE MACHINERY BROKE,
DIGGING LITERALLY WITH HER
HANDS IN ORDER TO TRY TO GET TO
THESE WORKERS.
HAVE WE HAD ANY UPDATES SO FAR?
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S EARLY.
BUT AS YOU, SAID THERE WAS A
HOSPITAL SET UP INSIDE THE
TUNNEL.
DO HAVE AN UPDATE ON THE HEALTH
OF THESE MEN?
>> I THINK WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT
A WHILE.
MAYBE OVERNIGHT, PERHAPS.
IT'SLREADY ABOUT 9:00 HERE IN
INDIA.
THAT IS LOCAL TIME.
IT'S DARK OUT THERE.
THE PRIORITY OBVIOUSLY IS TO
TAKE THEM TO A MEDICAL CENTER
TO ASSESS THEM OVERNIGHT, TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY NEEDS ARE
CATERED TO AT THIS POINT.
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH AS A
PRIMARY FOCUS FOR THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS WHO ARE TENDING TO
THESE MEN.
OVER THE LAST 70 DAYS, JULIA,
THERE HAVE BEEN PIPELINES
THROUGH WHICH OXYGEN HAS BEEN
SUPPLIED.
FOOD HAS BEEN SUPPLIED,
INITIALLY IT WAS DRY FOOD, WHEN
THEY HAD A WIDER PIPE IF THEY
STARTED SOMETHING IN COOKED
FOOD.
THERE IS WATER THAT'S BEEN SENT
IN.
MEDICINES, VITAMIN D, MOBILE
CHARGERS.
THEY HAVE ASSURED THAT WHATEVER
THEY COULD SUPPLY THESE MEN
WITH THROUGH THESE VERY NARROW
PIPELINES, MEDICAL ATTENDANTS,
MEDICAL SUPERVISORS HAVE BEEN
ON A MEGAPHONE WITH THEM OVER
THE PAST TWO WEEKS, THEY'VE
BEEN EX ASSESSING THEIR
CONDITION, TALKING TO THEM,
TELLING THEM TO EAT, TELLING
THEM TO HYDRATE THEMSELVES
ALONG WITH A CONSTANT ASSURANCE
THAT THEY WILL BE PULLED OUT.
THAT HAS CULMINATED INTO WHAT
WE'RE SEEING ON OUR SCREEN
TODAY, WHICH IS A HUGE SUCCESS.
NOT SURE --
SHORT OF A MIRACLE.
41 MEN PULLED, OUT EXTRACTED
FROM A TUNNEL THAT COLLAPSED
PARTIALLY ON THE 12TH OF
NOVEMBER DUE TO A LANDSLIDE IN
THE AREA.
THIS IS A VERY ECOLOGICAL
FRAGILE REGION.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS MUST BE
ASKED BY ENVIRONMENTALISTS, BY
ECOLOGICAL EXPERTS, THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD ALSO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AT THIS POINT FOR
WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
17 DAYS.
IT HAS BEEN NOTHING SHORT OF A
DISAPPOINTMENT TO HAVE THESE
MEN STUCK INSIDE THE TUNNEL.
BUT TODAY THERE HAS BEEN
SUCCESS AND, AT LEAST FOR THIS,
MOMENT THAT SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED, JULIA.
>> CERTAINLY.
YOU CALLED IT NOT FAR FROM A
MIRACLE.
MOST PEOPLE WATCHING THIS
CONSIDERED A MIRACLE, AFTER 17
DAYS DIMINISH TO GET FOOD,
WATER, OXYGEN TO THEM.
TO GET ALL 41 SAFELY OUT.
MAYBE WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT A FEW
HOURS NOW UNTIL WE HEAR ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH.
WE WILL KEEP OUR FINGERS
CROSSED ON THAT FRONT.
I THINK WE'RE WITNESSING A
MIRACLE IN NORTHERN INDIA TODAY,
WITH ALL 41 OF THOSE WORKERS
OUT.
VEDIKA, THE FAMILIES, WE CAN
ONLY IMAGINE.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN TALKING WITH
YOUR TEAM TO MANY OF THEM.
THE SHEER RELIEF AND JOY AT
GETTING THEIR WORKERS AND
FAMILY RELATIONS OUT SAFELY
AFTER 17 DAYS OF WHAT CAN ONLY